So very worried.
Secrecy is repugnant in a free and open
society.
And we are as a people inherently and
historic opposed to secret society to
secret oats and a secret proceedings.
But we are opposed around the world by a
monolithic and ruthless conspiracy that
relies primarily on cupboard,
means for expanding its sphere of
influence on infiltration instead of
invasion on severity.
And instead of elections on intimidation
instead of free choice.
It is a system which has conscripted
vast human and material resources into
the building of a tightly knit,
highly efficient machine that combines
military,
diplomatic,
intelligence,
economic,
scientific,
and political operations.
Its preparations are concealed,
not published.
It's mistakes a buried,
not headlined.
Its dissenters are silenced,
not praised.
No expenditure is questioned.
No rumor is printed.
No secret is revealed.
That is why the Athenian lawmaker solon
decreed it a crime for any citizen to
shrink from controversy.
But I am asking your help in the
tremendous task of informing and
alerting the American people confident
that with your help man will be what he
was born to be free and ended,
uh.